when I went to Mexico PE people would
like comment on me they would point at
me they like I stick out like a sore
thumb you know guys will walk by they'd
be like Chino and they start laughing
they do sh like that some guys would
like crack jokes with me they would be
like where you from you from North Korea
you from China so funny and I'm just
like uh I'm from
[Music]
China one of our M Brothers has fallen
um and it happened in a way super
similar to a story that we covered not
too long ago about a guy who uh you guys
remember there was a dude who traveled
to like Columbia or something and he got
on a dating app met a girl and then when
he met up with the girl he ended up
getting kidnapped and she was way too
hot for him remember that one oh I saw
this I saw this too he was M huh no that
guy wasn't oh but but this guy is and
what happened is that he's not just like
a m dude this guy is like an activist
like everybody knows he's from St Paul
is he the comedian guy yeah he's a
comedian guy his name Tang is that how
you say that I don't know how to speak M
but yes it looks like that uh he's a
professional comedian he's activist um
and he's 50 he travels to Medan pretty
often it seems like he kind of goes
there a lot and he likes it and he has
friends he knows people there um he's at
this carol G concert and uploaded a
video where he's there with this like
redheaded girl in the video like when
like pantser her she like turns away
real fast so then it's like a little bit
sus and then um it looks like that's the
same girl that he went out to dinner
with the last time he was in Columbia uh
a little over a month ago and then uh
one night he goes out for dinner and
then his brother and his friend end up
receiving a call from him saying that uh
he's being held at gunpoint and the
kidnappers want
$2,000 um and then the police get
notified they go to check his residence
and they find a girl there just rans
sacking his stuff oh the police catch
her but then they couldn't catch her she
got away wow she escaped and then um and
then there's nothing saying that that's
the same redheaded girl in the video or
anything but uh before any exchange
could be made for the uh Ransom or
anything they find his deceased body in
a ravine with stab wounds and blood
force trauma that is so sad man and
there's like certain uh speculations
that maybe he tried to escape so that
that's why they did that but there's no
telling at this moment this is some of
the trauma was like from what appeared
to be like a 60ft fall though too right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so and he
was there for Thanksgiving right yeah I
believe so yeah yeah that's so crazy and
he had been I got a business meeting man
I got I get the hell out of here all
right bye bye Joe why do you have to say
like that he had been communicating with
her online a lot right yeah yeah yeah
but also since they don't know if that's
the same girl I believe they did arrest
that redheaded woman in the videos and
photos but they don't yet know for sure
if the girl that he was with at that
time is that girl it could have been a
different one it could have b a
different group of people but they know
that he was talking to different people
that he hadn't yet met about hanging out
in median and stuff so can can you
comment on this at all what do you think
about this I was about to say straight
up can you just have just say a take say
do you think he's right or wrong I think
it's hilarious yeah yeah see that's sick
that's sick okay good before I I tell
you why it's hilarious can you tell me
what happened a man murder a man was Mur
you want to go with In Cold Blood huh a
man was found in a ravine multiple stab
wounds 60t drop drop
trauma
and according to you you don't think
that's funny nick don't good Lord Ken
dud IA Works man's wilding out yeah if
you take aaska I guess anything's funny
this is cool character no we're talking
about the we're talking about the mangi
that the activist that got murdered in
oh snap for real I didn't know that why
are you laughing dude yes I didn't cuz I
came in with no context do you know do
you know the story about that no I don't
I don't watch the news I only watch JK
news so smart so you don't know much I
don't D I don't know anything so they're
still trying to figure this [__] out
they're still trying to figure it out
yeah like you know how they like police
they always got to think of multiple
scenarios is one of them
like maybe maybe he's an activist he
fights for good but some a lot of people
also go to South America to look for
hoes and [__] yeah is he is the redhead
chick just a d a chick that she always
goes back to see and then this time she
set them up could also the girls might
be the suspect I mean there's a lot of
so like in terms of the past year yeah
there's like 250 incidents like this
yeah 250 cuz all these guys are going
over there where they're getting set up
to like go on what they think is a date
and then they end up getting either
robbed kidnapped or like something like
that you see all those Tik toks of those
guys being like I'm going to fly over to
Colombia me a [__] fing fine honey and
then you know yeah so it is common thing
that people I changed my mind gaming
though it's not funny thank you but it's
like Colombian women are so attractive
it's like I'm just going to roll the
[__] Dice and see what yeah it's a
it's a honeypop and I'm going to do it
in Medan columia because to be fair yeah
they got great track record to be fair
he does post a lot of photos with like
really beautiful coloman women like dude
if you're if you're okay look I'll say
this if you're going to Columbia and
you're not partaking in like the fine
Honeys then sh doing my yeah I mean not
that he's like not that he's doing
anything nefarious but like if he is
going to like meet people and like and
if he just enjoys Columbia and Medan and
everything and you know just happens to
meet somebody what if he's a big coffee
guy doubt it
no he's either getting some drugs to
bring back home to sell in the states
or's TR you don't think it's like a
jealous boyfriend or a jealous dude
that's been stalking this Colombian [__]
I think it could be all the above dude
if if if I go into my Criminal Mind then
I would think that the reason they go on
so many dates before striking is just to
sus out how much they can Poss POS get
if they get away with to build rapport
this trust I bet you they have some sort
of like partner that's working with them
and then they like you said like they
like bait they bait these guys into it
that is what happened that is what
happened the last case that we said that
was just like this where uh a dude kind
of like I hate to say it but like it
looked like like out of his League like
not this one but then the last one it
looked like he matched with a girl that
was like way hot too much woman for him
so he's super it's almost like even if
that was me I would be like I don't
trust this I'd be like why is this right
just like you all do you go like when
you see an account with like a like a
porn hot looking woman you're like oh
that's probably spam so you should think
like that in real life too I think I
agree you know what I mean why do you
think guys ignore those signs is it
because I think it's cuz they're horny
and they're dumb yeah they're horny as
[__] and then so their [__] spider
senses are off and and they're wishing
for it to be true cuz they're so lonely
when will we learn and I'm sure also too
those ladies know how to [__] play
the game
or they got money cuz when you got
money it happens sometimes well grandmas
and Grandpa falling for all kind of
scams same [__] because they're lonely
their kids moved out nobody's talking to
them they want someone to talk to the
and then these scammers talk to them and
they're kind D they talk to them for a
while Elder scamming is always going to
be hot plus I know I don't know but
there's definitely spots in like even
like in Europe and stuff where like the
[__] multi-millionaires the
billionaires going party and stuff and
it's just like the girls all their their
entire goal is to [__] get pregnant
with one of these dudes because once
they do they're set think about that
bagging a basketball player it doesn't
[__] matter what they look like if
they got billions all you got to do is
get their seed and [__] [__] yeah you
know is is uh is is there such thing as
toxic femininity no K come on don't say
that dude look at the [__] look at
the set behind you because cuz cuz you
know how guys have that masculine trait
that's like super toxic to whatever
right and then girls also have a
feminine side that they could use
against guys to like lure them or
whatever PVP dude but is that is that a
thing PVP PVP every Everybody yeah I'm
sure I mean that's what the that's
essentially the Honeypot syndrome right
oh that's what it's called Honeypot yeah
you never been honey before but it does
suck that like I mean if you're not from
a country and you go out there it's like
you should take extra precautions I
agree man I think you got to be very
careful when you go to a different
country I think if you have the money
you fly hert out yeah you don't fly
there but but honestly like I did I had
a neighbor who would go to median a ton
and I was like dude you're nuts and he's
like no it's not what you think like I
know you like because you've watched all
this like Escobar [__] and all these
like documentaries and and movies he's
like but it's not like that nowadays
it's so safe and it's so cool to go
there and it's cheap and he's like
always talking me into it and I'm like
but I'm still scared yeah for sure but I
also think it's like you know in the
same geographical location there's
multiple worlds yeah that's true yeah
yeah yeah you're right yeah right like
in the sgv you have like the police
world then you have apparently there's a
whole prostitution ring in this in the
city and there's like you know there's
all these worlds but if you're not
looking for those worlds they're like
they're blind to them so your friend
could be oh I'm a fisherman fishing
scene is crazy especially if you if you
if you go to Columbia and you look like
a foreigner they will treat you like one
bro and you're swiping in order to look
for hoes that's what I mean bro like you
got to be careful like you can't be I
think if you're doing online dating yeah
if do online dating and you go to a
place like Colombia I mean it's probably
cuz all the people I know that go to
Colombia they're looking for that
redhaired chick yeah they're looking for
those chick BR but it's like when we
it's like when we hear about a guy who
got murdered locally and we're like wait
this place is pretty safe and then we
find out he was into drugs and [__] and
like like are you saying like these
people sort of like attract this type of
life to no we're not saying they deserve
it can I didn't say that no I'm saying
like you're I'm saying like the stuff
you do is bringing these things these
elements closer you're looking for hoes
you're looking for underground world I'm
not saying it's their fault but it's
just unfortunate that they had to place
him as a mark Cuz you know like there's
probably lots of guys that they let pass
by that they're just like oh there's not
much we can get from him or we'll get
caught or it's too risky but it's really
unfortunate that they they saw this dude
and however long they worked on him that
they ended up saying like oh he's he's a
good Target and then for it to get
botched like that I mean 2,000 bucks who
wouldn't pay that for their homie to
like get out of being they didn't get
anything from this guy what it sounds
like they ransacked his place and that's
it do you think they're already like
they know that they're going to murder
this dude anyway because like Witnesses
but they're still trying to get the
ransom you think that's their game like
get the ransom and kill the [__]
Witnesses I think they're trying to get
their cash that's what I think but they
just killed this guy and didn't get the
cash yeah that's why it's like if they
just murdered him like that it could
have been some sort of like fight they
were having or something so [__] went
down that's the that's what they're like
assuming that like something had
happened he tried to escape maybe and
then it went bad and I'm sure they're
going to find they're going to do it
again sure they're going to find this's
a comedian right yeah comedian activist
yeah comedian activist uh in the big in
the M community in St Paul wood Woodbury
Community yeah you got to be careful out
here man feel weird and closer to home
that's like imagining like Joe going out
there trying to find his life you know I
mean we already saw a story I mean very
similar to this so like now that there's
two of these and I can tell you there's
over 250 this past year
be really careful when neighbor count
safe dude don't fun when you travel but
it's like Bart said there's different
worlds like he's uh he's he's a
documentary producer he goes out there
all the time he ended up marrying a
Colombian woman brought her back to the
States you know that's different but I I
do think it's good to like if you're
trying to travel and have fun and like
wholesome fun like definitely look and
try to aim towards that direction but
still be aware of the Dark World as well
well you know so that [__] like that
doesn't happen but you can still have
fun because it sucks to travel somewhere
new and just be afraid of everything
well I think that's it's it's not even
so much fear it's like respect it's like
when you go to Mexico like you have to
have a respect for certain things like
yeah bro when I went to Mexico PE people
would like comment on me they would
point at me they'd [__] like I stick
out like a sore thumb you know guys will
walk by they' be like Chino and they
start laughing they do [__] like that
some guys would like crack jokes with me
that would be like where you from you
from North Korea you China so funny and
I'm just like uh I'm from China you know
like just random [__] where I'm like
dude this is so [__] random yeah yeah
and then people they look at you funny
when we're in guadalahara and it's a
it's a nice area for sure but you just
understand that like I'm a foreigner
here yeah you're the Foreigner I'm going
to be on my best behavior and like I'm
going to keep my head down bro yeah like
I'm just going to be kind of in no D you
should act like you own the place like
come in there like entitled Americans
you know leaving JW at home like Hey
where's my freaking Margarita you know
you should do that so guys if you guys
are traveling abroad and you're into
those dating apps or talking to girls
online be really careful uh don't be the
third case this year that we have to
cover and sucks to happen to good people
but don't want trouble that's what you
have want trouble you know my parents
were in Brazil and then my dad was just
like sitting on the [__] like just
like near the beach and stuff and then
some dudes ran by and they yanked the
chain off of his [__] neck and my dad
was trying to chase him I was like you
crazy fool my God you can keep up it
activated his Asian anger yeah no did he
say that
probably know you cannot say the after
you get Chan yank yeah be safe out there
man and we can't afford to lose any more
Ms so yeah yeah look behind your back
Have Eyes behind your back heck yeah
unlike
[Music]
Nick